Wisconsin's presidential primary
election happening today last night the
state Supreme Court overturning a
last-minute executive order by the
governor to suspend in-person voting
until June Mike Tobin is live with the
latest on all that hey Mike hi Sandra
Wisconsin voters who choose to are going
to the polls today after 18 chaotic
hours and to High Court decisions that
handed defeats to Wisconsin's Democratic
governor the state Supreme Court which
is controlled by Republicans told eavers
he may not delay the election until June
and the US Supreme Court said absentee
ballots must be postmarked today now the
challenge to delaying the vote was
brought by Republican state lawmakers
and that brought the ire of eavers who
wrote thousands will wake up and have to
choose between their right to vote and
staying healthy and safe Republicans in
Wisconsin who control the legislature
pushed back against the delay and eva's
efforts at a mail-in vote they said
eva's brought the changes too late
they should have dealt with this weeks
ago
unfortunately weeks ago the governor
himself a Democrat was saying there
should be an election Oh two weeks ago
or less than two weeks ago he said he
couldn't do anything and then just days
ago he called for a special session and
today he switched yet again saying they
were going to post fall in to the
Democratic state senator Tim carpenter
said Wisconsin is the only state stupid
enough to have an election April 7th
roughly 1.3 million absentee ballots
have been requested the Election
Commission predicts clerks will be
overwhelmed many Wisconsin i'ts are
complaining they have not received their
absentee ballots in the mail yet
Milwaukee usually has 100 polling
stations open duty shortages of
volunteers five are operating the
National Guard has been activated and
Guardsmen and women have been trained to
be volunteers at polling locations it's
not going to look like martial law then
what were they where plainclothes and
work in the counties where they live
Sandra Mike Tobin reporting from Chicago
for us this morning Mike thanks